Ariana Grande and Pete Davidson are
already going furniture shopping
meanwhile Milan turns 20 and only on
with the Disney heroine herself plus
it's the daily Deni one-year anniversary
hello world this is the daily Deni and
if you can believe it exactly one year
ago today was her very first show to
celebrate I'm wearing the same outfit
from the day we launched it still fits
all right guys the set has changed I
like to think my hair got better but you
know what my thirst is still real now
normally I'd save the celebrating for
the end of the video but it's a special
occasion right and I'm thirsty I was
expecting that to be a lot more
traumatic all right here we go toasting
to wine here guys thank you so much for
to the peeps who have stuck around from
the very beginning I hope you've enjoyed
this tea as much as I'm gonna enjoy the
champagne
to you guys thank you so so much oh
that's good
all right but we still do have a show to
do I'm a hold on to this though it's
time to check back in with lovebirds
ariana grande and Pete Davidson clearly
Ari is loving her engaged life and it
looks like she's more than ready to
settle down yesterday that 24 year old
and her fiance were spotted furniture
shopping in New York City
the singer rocked an oversized
sweatshirt and $1,700 gucci boots cuz
that's what I wear when I'm hitting a
Restoration Hardware you know man
now the furniture shopping comes just
one day after the couple got matching
tattoos which a few of their friends got
to it reads h2 g/km oh that stands for
honest-to-god knock me out it's also a
phrase that Ari has tweeted once and
fans have been using a lot all right if
the new eat eat isn't a sign of
commitment whelmed wasted already well
there's also a new track on Ari's
upcoming album sweetener
she told fans on Twitter life's too
short to be quick cryptic about
something as beautiful as this love
she's in to that I say go belt it from
the rooftop then girl last night we
caught up with Ariana's older brother
Frankie at Broadway sings for prides
revolution annual charity concert and
he's on board with her world win romance
- I mean I'm so happy for my sister for
my whole family
it's a big year for her sweeteners
coming very excited the lightest coming
is coming out in like minutes which are
very unbelievably excited about there's
an interlude called Pete on the album
yes I've heard the whole thing it's it's
truly remarkable it's a remarkable piece
of work just as a family were in a
really good place it's a time to
celebrate it's joy it's happiness it's
it's it's kind of just
it's the Grande's a year and that's all
I'm gonna say you know oh God look out
for us because windy everywhere he's not
lying they will be everywhere in fact
Ariana's new single the light is coming
drops tonight all right guys so not only
are we celebrating the one-year
anniversary of the daily Denny but it's
also the 20th anniversary of one of the
most groundbreaking Disney and
movies ever Mulan I got a chance to chat
with the voice of the Disney heroine
herself me now when about mulan's impact
20 years later on the 20th anniversary
of this film can you believe that I mean
what do you remember most about being
part of this special film I just
remember being so taken aback that
Disney was able to take an all-asian
story and was brave enough 20 years ago
to go you know what we want to make this
story because it's an incredible one and
it's very inspiring about a young girl
who really followed her heart and
believed in herself sorry I mean sorry
you have to see that I've been such a
Disney fan since I was a little girl
that for me this is just sort of like
one of those moments where I feel like
I'm in a Twilight Zone world you know
where there's reality like this is
happening and yet I'm living out my
fantasy
Tanana is having you for a daughter
quickly before you go thoughts on the
live action that they're gonna be doing
yes will you be a part of it I'm not
allowed to say but fingers crossed
[Music]
now the baby is all grown up and safe in
China I love that movie so much for
those hoping me na will reprise her role
as Mulan in the live-action retelling
Disney actually cast Chinese actress Liu
Li Fei and so far Disney has made good
on casting a primarily Chinese cast for
this so I'm excited and I'm also so
excited because guys a year ago we
didn't know what this show is gonna be
and now it's here 365 days later thank
you guys so much for watching thank you
to Beyonce for the Daily Inspiration but
we really do appreciate all you viewers
and while it's been super fun hasn't
always been perfect so in honor of 365
days of me here are some of my favorite
bloopers enjoy and thank you guys once
again for watching the daily Denny
cheers to one year we're gonna break
down the most memorable looks tomorrow
so into la la my name it's clear that
for dead four doctor's name these two
have been at each other for years and
you if I just read what's on the
prompter
Wyoming they where Jackson Hole Wyoming
damn it
meanwhile kendall Jenner stepped out
with rumored new boy oh good